amis téléspectateurs bonjour et
bienvenue sur le plateau dès maintenant
l'émission qui revient toujours avec
plaisir et toujours avec vous sur
l'actualité politique de la semaine vous
connaissez le principe hashtag et
maintenant si vous souhaitez réagir dans
ce numéro les amis nous sommes gâtés oui
j'ai autour de moi des invités 5 étoiles
ils ont tout vu tout lu tout compris à
cette semaine politique il viennent nous
la raconter quelle joie de vous
retrouver Emmanuel voget bonsoir très
bien vous êtes communiquant président de
narrative à côté de vous plaisir
également de vous retrouver hline
Terzian ça va bonjour ça va très bien
vous êtes journaliste politique à RMC
faut-il vous présenter Michel cota
bonjour bonjour vous êtes éditorialiste
à Europa merci d'être avec nous vous
publiez cette semaine vos mémoires
politiques votre livre s'intitule ma 5e
c'est à retrouver aux éditions bouquin
je signale également votre documentaire
présidant le prix à payer face face à la
société c'est à voir ce weekend sur
Public Sénat et le grand pierre
Jacquemain est aussi sur ce plateau
bonjour bonjour leussi grand sty
rédacteur en chef à Politis le dernier
numéro de la revue s'intitule Le mythe
du juge rouge dans cette émission on se
demandera si l'on est en train
d'assister à la chute de la maison
Mélenchon alors qu'une de ses proches
est dans le viseur de la justice on
verra si leur en voquier est vraiment
l'homme de la situation à droite lui qui
a décidé de sortir du bois cette semaine
on reviendra sur les solutions de du
gouvernement après les émeutes de cet
été sur le chaos politique qui touche
actuellement nos amis
américains est ouverte merci président
Larché un anniversaire oui celui de la
constitution de la 5e République elle a
eu 65 ans cette semaine peut-être large
de prendre sa retraite diront certains
en tout cas mercredi Emmanuel Macron a
célébré cet anniversaire en proposant de
faire évoluer certains dispositifs il a
notamment relancé le débat sur
l'utilisation du référendum écoutez on
ne révise pas la Constitution sous le
coup de l'émotion pour répondre à des
modes ou pour la beauté du geste il
existe encore des domaines importants
pour la vie de la nation qui échappent
au chant de l'article 11 de notre
Constitution et je souhaite que nous
puissions trouver collectivement les
moyens de mener à son terme ce chantier
en lien étroit avec président de nos
assemblées mais disons-le avec clarté
étendre le champ du référendum ne peut
permettre et ne saurait permettre de se
soustraire aux règles de l'État de droit
comme je l'
de même la souveraineté populaire peut
également s'exprimer directement à
l'issue d'un référendum d'initiative
partagé pierre la 5e République a fait
son temps oui je pense que il y a nos
institutions sont obsolètes on le voit
quasiment quotidiennement à travers le
jeu institutionnel je sais pas s'il faut
changer de régime il faut à mon avis
considérablement retravailler repenser
nos institution je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un sentiment
personnel en tout cas je je je crois que
l'élection au suffrage universel celle
direct du président de la République me
paraît obsolète je vois que la question
de la démocratie est quand même une
préoccupation majeure des Français l'une
des dernières crises celle des gilets
jaunes l'a largement démontré avec cette
revendication qui était celle du
référendum d'initiative citoyenne je
crois que l'absence de représentativité
des Français dans nos chambres
parlementaires pose question et donc
doit nous interroger sur le mode de
fonctionnement démocratique pour plus de
de démocratie dans notre pays je parlais
du Parlement mais je parle aussi en
terme de démocratie sociale on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui le rôle des
des des syndicats le rôle des élus
locaux enfin tout ça n'est pas
véritablement associé au jeux
démocratique donc je pense que oui il
faut revoir fondamentalement mais on
peut pas se servir de la Constitution
pour des arrangements politiques tels
que Emmanuel Macron semble vouloir fa
Michel a pris beaucoup de notes pendant
votre pr de parole il faut il faut la
réviser cette constitution vous l'avez
bien connu évidemment vous sortez un
bouquin consacré à la 5 je pense qu'elle
a résisté à beaucoup de choses qu'elle a
résister notamment à
l'alternance je ne pense pas qu'il fa la
changer je pense qu'il qu'il faut
peut-être l'aménager et notamment en
ouvrant sans doute euh le les
référendums la possibilité de référendum
euh pour euh euh les questions de
société euh et aussi peut-être mais ça
je suis plus sceptique là-dessus parce
que euh tout dépend des modalités on
peut faire un référendum d'initiative
populaire mais s'il y a une personne qui
décide c'est pas possible euh s' en a 10
millions c'est trop euh donc le problème
est dans la les modalités donc moi je me
méfie de la façon dont les choses vont
être présentées et dont elles vont
sortir de cette grande discussion dans
lequel personne n'est d'accord hein h
pourquoi Emmanuel Macron fait cette
sortie maintenant il a un intérêt
politique à le faire Emmanuel Macron il
a essayé à deux reprises de le faire ça
n'a pas marché été 2018 on est dans
l'affaire benala l'année d'après ça n'a
pas marché non plus il a un intérêt
politique on est en dans un contexte de
majorité relative il doit donner des
gages aux oppositions alors en voul
voulant élargir les critères pour
recourir au au référendum c'est une
façon de séduire la droite et l'extrême
droite qui aimerait que ce soit ouvert à
l'immigration en ouvrant également en
facilitant le le recours au RIP pour
référendum d'initiative partagé et en
inscrivant l'IV dans la Constitution
c'est une façon de séduire la gauche il
sait aussi qu' a une desaspirations
démocratiques de la part des Français
les gilets jaunes c'était une façon de
dire on a besoin d'être représenté c'est
une façon de répondre au aux émeutes
aussi connu qui ont eu fin juin et début
juillet maintenant est-ce que les vont
lui faire ce cadeau à Emmanuel Macron de
pouvoir réviser la
Constitution ce que dit votre voisine je
vous paraphraser c'est que c'est on est
presque dans la manœuvre politique enfin
y a une arrièrepensée politique VO le
racourissement la sortie du contexte le
monde où on vit
alors tout d'abord moi je pense que pour
célébrer la les 65 ans de la la 5e
République il convient de ne pas
commencer par dire pour la célébrer
changeons là voilà ça c'est le premier
point le second point c'est que vous
avez raison il essae de de rassembler
tout le monde ce qu'il n'a jamais réussi
à faire et d'être finalement dans le
vent mais le problème c'est que à force
de vouloir être dans le vent il risque
d'avoir un destin de feuille morte le
président de la République parce que il
n'a aucune majorité pour faire un truc
comme ça personne ne lui fera ce cadeau
il a une majorité relative quand on
change la Constitution il faut qu'il y
ait une bonne raison pour le faire il
faut être dans une position de force
quand même politique ce qui n'est pas
son cas et il faut être capable de
donner une perspective à ce qu'on veut
faire or là la seule perspective qui
nous est offerte c'est j'utilise le le
les le 65 anniversaire 65e anniversaire
de la Constitution pour proposer quelque
chose qu'on vient de sortir du carton la
pendant les après la crise des gilets
jaunes effectivement il y a eu une
demande pour un référendum pour un
référendum élargi qu'il il a dit
d'accord avant d'immédiatement remettre
ça sous son dans son tiroir et pu là
maintenant il essaie de faire croire
qu'il y aurait un consensuson vous de la
poudre aux yeux euh Michel c'est quoi le
secret de cette longévité de la 5e
République 65 ans on l'a dit c'était
l'anniversaire cette semaine c'est quoi
le secret de C c'est quand même un
équilibre entre les institutions c'est
pas un système présidentiel beaucoup de
gens parmi les journalistes se disent
oui régime présidentiel c'est mieux mais
enfin on voit quand même ses ses limites
et et c'est un régime qui reste même si
le Parlement est affaibli mais au fond
il est plus affaibli par la qualité de
ces hommes et de ses femmes que par sa
fonction elle-même elle pourrait faire
il pourrait faire ce qu'il veut c'est
exactement ce qu' dit Jean-Louis Debray
sur le plateau de Public Sénat cette
semaine on va l'écouter je vous redonne
la parole Michel dans un instant on va
écouter Jean-Louis Debray
plus le climat politique est détérioré
plus ces institutions montrent leur
utilité euh le le pouvoir actuel pour
pourrait remercier tous les matins les
constituants de 1958 euh si ils ont
traversé la crise des gilets jaunes sans
qu'il y ait en plus une crise
ministérielle euh c'est bien parce que
les institutions ont donné les moyens au
gouvernement
euh de diriger le pays le problème c'est
pas le texte c'est les gens qui sont
chargés d'animer cette constitution
c'est ça c'est c'est le
euh c'est le désordre apparent de
l'Assemblée nationale qui quand même euh
fait douter de de de toute la
construction euh et puis c'est aussi de
certaine façon euh et surtout même les
difficultés du président de la
République h moi je dirais ce qui me
paraît important dans le dans ce
référendum je me demande siand
mê rérend la première intention de
d'Emmanuel Macron n'est pas de gagner du
temps parce que ça dans le débat
politique ça vous nourrit bien un débat
pendant un an un an et
demi donc on arrive à 24
25 comme alors dans le référendum au
fond vous savez beaucoup de gens se
disaient est-ce qu'il va prévoir un 3è
mandat bon non il l'a exclu par
conséquent il gag du temps jusqu'en 25
jusqu'en 25 et après en 25 ce sera
quelqu'un d'autre qui prendra prendra le
départ je vais vous montrer cette
tribune du constitutionnaliste Dominique
Rousseau qui est paru dans Le Monde
cette semaine il nous dit la chose
suivante une révision constitutionnelle
s'impose sous peine de rendre inévitable
une révolution le problème n'est pas de
faire une éème révision par et pour les
élus mais une refondation
constitutionnelle par et pour les
citoyens ça vous plaît ça pierre je je
trouve que l'analyse de crousseau dans
le monde est vraiment très intéressante
parce que elle fait suite aussi à
différents événements et quand je disais
tout à l'heure que il y avait un
caractère assez obsolè de nos
institutions c'est que tout le monde a
en tête quand même que ce gouvernement
gouverne à coup de 493 sur des objets
des sujets qui sont extrêmement
structurants pour la vie des Français la
question des retraites le fait qu'il y a
une opposition massive des Français et
que le gouvernement soit passé en force
y compris face au devant le Parlement en
imposant un 493 ça pose question
justement sur le renouvellement et ce
caractère que je que je que je qualifie
d'obsolète de nos institutions je Perm
mais juste une chose parce que Emmanuel
Macron dans sa volonté de réviser notre
notre Constitution je je trouve que ce
qui ça pourrait être intéressant c'est
un débat de société c'est un débat qui
nous concerne tout d'autres ont choisi
des processus constituants pour renouvel
les institutions je trouve que là où ça
va pas c'est que un des principaux
points qui veut toucher c'est la
question des droits en fait quand la
Constitution il y a au moins une chose
qui est bonne dans notre Constitution
c'est son préambule le droit la la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et en
fait dans la pensée d'Emmanuel Macron
puisque l'objectif c'est d'ouvrir le les
objets de la des référendum et donc
d'aller demander au pens s'ils sont pour
ou contre plus ou moins d'immigration
par exemple pour satisfaire
effectivement la droite et l'extrême
droite là on y va pour justement réduire
les droits des hommes donc est que je
dire c'est que son objectif il est pas
bon quoi il va pas avec notre la
philosophie même de ce qu'a été notre
Constitution c'est
notamment la Déclaration des Droits de
l'Homme vous parliez de cet article 493
on le rappelle qui permet l'adoption
d'une loi sans vote au Parlement elle a
été utilisée à de nombreuses reprises
par ellisabeth borne on va voir ce
sondage paru il y a quelques jours
l'article 493 et non démocratique pour
70 % des Français selon une étude Haris
interactif publiée le 3 octobre il y a
un problème avec cet article oui il y a
un problème avec cet article mais c'est
pas parce que un article pose problème
que l'ensemble de l'édifice est à jeter
aux Ortis il faut effectivement réformer
moi je pense la Constitution je pense
qu'elle a aussi cette vertu qui est
d'avoir été créé pour un temps qui n'est
pas le nôtre et avoir traversé tous les
temps pour solidifier les temps les
temps difficiles dans lesquels on est ça
veut pas dire qu'elle est par en fait ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut pas qu'elle
s'adapte le 493 n'a pas de sens c'est
évident mais mais le président de la
République réussit finalement plutôt
bien son cout puisque moi je je suis
intimement persuadé que tout dans 3 mois
on en parle plus
hein de cette révision
constitutionnelle mais mais en attendant
il nous fait il nous fait discuter sur
ce plateau pendant pendant une
demi-heure d'un truc sans lendemain sans
lendemain il n'a pas enfin il faut
regarder les choses en face c'està-dire
que il n'a aucune majorité pour faire ça
il a pas de projet qui rassemble et qui
fasse consensus et il est à un moment
politique de son mandat de son second
mandat dans laquelle il ne peut pas
engager une révision constitutionnelle
et et en plus il a perdu le sens du pays
est-ce que franchement les Français sont
tous obsédés par la Révolution la
réforme de la Constitution par les temps
qui courent est
présidentqu ve dire c'est qu'il il est
hor sol partout on parle de la vie chè
on parle de on parle on parle de la VI
du problème des Français face à la
montée des carburants il don il donne
100 € il aurait mieux fait de rien
donner parce que c'est ridicule pour les
Français qui l'utilise partout où il est
partout depuis la rentrée mais mais il
est nulle part je trouve dans la manière
d'incarner ce qu'il ce qu'il essaie
d'incarner ce qui est intéressant c'est
que les Français plébiscitent la réforme
des institutions et la réforme de la
Constitution et à côté de ça c'est très
intéressant ils estiment qu' y avait un
sondage dans dans le Figaro cette
semaine qui disait que c'était pas leur
priorité et c'est PhIP je crois qui a
dit également que ils ét plus intéressé
par le pouvoir d'achat et par le prix du
carburant que par une réforme des sontil
intéressés par Laurent vqu les français
Laurent vqui en tout cas sort de sa tère
cette semaine alors qu'à droit certains
reprochent au président de la région
auverneuronal de se faire trop discret
il était l'invité de la rentrée des
jeunes républicains il y a quelques
jours il a fixé une stratégie pour 2027
écoutez-le j'ai mesuré ce qu' l' en
coûte de sérénité et de détermination
pour déverrouiller la République
française et aujourd'hui j'y suis Pr
il faut oser imaginer un nouveau
modèle il faut prendre le temps ce que
nous ne faisons plus d'écouter les
attentes et les aspirations des Français
c'est à cela que je vais consacrer toute
mon énergie vous conduire à nouveau vers
un grand succès
collectif HL on a envie de dire enfin on
va le invoquer oui alors je sais pas
s'il a convaincu avec ce discours bon ça
c'est au au téléspectateurs de dej et au
français je pense que c'est straté
stiquement intelligent d'imposer un
candidat naturel à droite c'est ce que
veut ériic cotti l'éviter de s'infliger
les guerres intestines au au sein de de
LR en enlevant des statuts l'idée d'une
primaire on a vu ce que ça a donné aux
deux dernières présidentielles bon il y
a eu fin c'est particulier et surtout
les 4,8 % de de Valérie PCR maintenant
Laurent voquier donc ok candidat naturel
on voit le discours je sais pas si ça
embarque les foule ensuite il a cette
stratégie de silence médiatique je ne
sais pas si ça marche non plus il veut
capitaliser sur cette image de président
de région les les régions heureuses les
territoires heureux je ne sais pas si ça
marche dans les sondages en tout cas
c'est pas le cas et surtout il a des il
y a des candidats en embuscade il y a un
certain David lisner qui est est
derrière le maire de Cann président de
la MF certes pas très connu du grand
public mais qui inaugure un QG à Paris
qui a quelques soutiens et et il est pas
très bien placé le renvoquer pour
l'instant dans les sondages il y a des
Édouard Philippe même des Bruno Le Maire
Gérald haranin Xav Bertrand qui prennent
la place à droite
il vous embarque laurentquier cher
emmanueli mon avis personnel a peu
d'importance dans l'histoire mais je je
pense qu' il sort surtout parce qu'il
comprend qu'il est en train de prendre
un retard qui se rattrape pas et comme
disait celui qui l' féministe quand on
prend le toboggan quand on commence à
descendre on remonte pas le problème
c'est qu'il part du il est parti pour
pas le nommer il part du principe que le
il est parti du principe que le silence
crée l' tente le problème c'est qu'il
n'est ni attendu ni désiré mis à part
par Éric cotti et sa bande et et et et
la présidence d'ericotti menait à ça il
a été mis là pour ça avec comme seul
objectif de faire la place à
laurentvoquier sauf que bah l'attente
elle a accouché d'une d'un désamour
personne n'attend n'attend
laurentvoquier la la sortie l'arrivée en
politique fracassante de de Monsieur
Zemour réduit l'espace de cette droite
Rance qu'il incarne qui divise les
Français qui les monent les uns contre
les autres mais il a en revanche et ça
je je le reconnais un talent incroyable
pour dire aux gens ce qu'ils ont envie
d'entendre certains aux républicains
disent que quand on sert la main de
Laurent vqui après il faut recomter ses
doigts donc donc il est capable de tout
finalement et même de renverser la table
qui pierre ce retour ce comeback de le
de Monsieur vquier d'abord vous posez la
question de savoir qui était le candidat
s'il était le candidat naturel de la
droite Laurent vquier n'est pas le
candidat naturel de la droite le
candidat naturel de la droite il
s'appelle Édouard Philippe il s'appelle
Gérald Darmanin il s'appelle Gabriel
Atal il s'appelle
le le le candidat naturel de la droite
c'est un macroniste c'est c'est c'est ce
qui va se jouer et par ailleurs le parti
prix qui est celui aujourd'hui des
républicains c'est-à-dire la
reconstruction presque idéologique des
républicains ne paraît pas du tout
s'inscrire dans l'histoire de ce qui a
été le RPR puis l'UMP et aujourd'hui les
républicains ils ont cette stratégie
tous ceux qui émergent aujourd'hui chez
les républicains que ce soit monsieur
sooti que ce soit monsieur voké que ce
soit monsieur lisnart aussi aujourd'hui
ont un parti prix qui cherche à aller
prendre des voix à l'extrême droite mais
dans l'histoire de France que ce soit la
gauche ou que ce soit la droite quand
elle a couru après l'extrême droite
c'est toujours l'extrême droite qui a
qui a gagné donc la stratégie qui est
celle des républicains ne me paraît pas
la bonne je je pense que les
républicains auraient voulu se
réinscrire dans une droite sociale
reprendre le créneau peut-être d'assumer
ce qui a été le golisme puis le
chirakisme et cetera sans doute ils
auraient pu réémerger dans l'espace
politique mais là en faisant ce qu'il
font je pense que la droite est soluble
dans le macronisme et d'ailleurs ce qui
se passe au Sénat on le voit les
positions des sénateurs de droite n'est
pas celle des des députés de droite et
que il y a sans doute au Sénat un Macron
compatible un macronisme compatible avec
la droite des républiquain on a
l'impression que beaucoup revendiquent
cet héritage du RPR est-ce que leur en
voquier est l'héritier du RPR historique
michelout pas pas franchement je vous
rappelle quand même les conditions de
son départ il y a pas tellement
longtemps il était quand même à la tête
des républicains il a été obligé d'en
partir ça c'est le premier point deuxème
point moi je méfie toujours des gens qui
vous disent faut prendre les choses de
très haut surtout regardons d' haut ne
nous la sont pas en
lisé moi ça me fait peur parce que ça
recouvre le plus souvent un vide de
peut-être pas de de la pensée dans le
cadre Deok je ne diraiis pas ça mais
invite de l'action en tout cas quis
qu'on a dit qu'on est en haut oui ben on
y reste et puis je trouve en effet sur
la stratégie je ne comprends rien à la
stratégie des républicains je ne
comprends rien d'abord un ils sont un
petit nombre mais en plus ils se divise
déjà c'est ensuite ils pensent que c'est
eux qui vont récupérer les voix les voix
du Front du rassemblement national et
les voix les plus extrémistes or ils
sont trop petits pour les récupérer et
en revanche il continuent à penser que
ceux qui un jour ont contribué à
l'action d'Emmanuel Macron sont tous et
également à rejeter alors je ne vois pas
avec qui pour faire une unité et en tout
cas la sol unité que je vois c'est avec
Marine Le Pen Nicolas Sarkozi s'est
exprimé cette semaine sur le retour de
de Laurent voquier il lui apporté un
soutien un soutien plutôt modéré mais un
soutien quand même écoutez-le il a été
mon ministre pendant 5 ans c'est un
garçon très
talentueux avec qui j'ai des liens
d'amitié et je préfère quand il parle
que quand il stit parce que je ne crois
pas pour prendre une image sportive moi
qui aime tellement le sport qu'on gagne
Roland Garos en jouant petit bras j'ai
dit tout le bien que je pensais de
Monsieur Gérald Arman que j'aime
beaucoup après il y a un pleoton et on
verra dans la montée de l'alpedes c'està
dire quand on s'approchera de la
présidentielle celui qui va se détacher
Nicolas Sarkozi qui soutient donc
Laurent vquier ça vaut quoi le soutien
de de Sarco
rien rien mais pour enfin je dis pas ça
pour être insultant avec l'ancien
Président je je dis ça vous mentez mais
vous un peu aussi
parfois je dis ça simplement parce que
ce qui a fait les grandes heures du du
RPR c'est était effectivement un corpus
d'idées qui faisait consensus et c'était
surtout parce que la droite républicaine
a besoin de ça d'un leadership Jacques
Chirac a été ce leader Nicolas Sarkozi à
sa façon a été ce leader et et depuis il
n'y a plus aucun
leadership la question c'est qui peut
incarner ce leadership la droite elle
doit se rassembler derrière des idées
mais elle doit derrière se rassembler
derrière un chef et il y a plus de chef
euh fais une primaire faisons une
primaire mais non on a bien vu où ça
menait vous savez un chef quelle est la
définition d'un leader ça n'est pas
celui qui s'impose c'est celui qu'on
choisi là où on ne pourrait pas aller
seul mais personne dans le texte c'est
du Nicolas Sarkozi ah non non non non
non non ça c'est pas du Nicolas Sarkozi
dans le texte Nicolas Sarkozi il
s'impose c'est ce qui est totalement
justement l'inverse de ce que je viens
de raconter mais non non non non ce que
je veux dire c'est que personne n'est
capable aujourd'hui de dire au
républicains je vais vous emmener là où
vous n'êtes pas capable d'aller pour
pour une raison simple c'est que vous
parliez de stratégie pierre mais
derrière la stratégie il faut qu'il y
ait un corpus d'idée or moi le corpus
d'idée des républicains je ne l'ai pas
compris je ne le vois pas la seule chose
qu'il est rassemble et en plus il est
totalement paradoxal parce que ce que
disait Nicolas Sarkozi quand il dit je
préfère Laurent vquer quand il parle
plutôt que quand il sautait il pointe
aussi l'idée que quand même monsieur
vquer a étit totalement absent dans
débat sur les retraites quand même et ça
lui est reproché parce queement enfin
philosophiquement la droite des
républains était totalement d'accord
avec remble aujourd'hui les républicains
c'est leur D ils sont d'accord sur rien
la question c'est est-ce que un homme
comme Édouard Philippe peut incarner
au-delà des républicains il y a plus que
30 ou 40000 adhéren c'est-à-dire rien
est-ce que Édouard Philippe par exemple
peut incarner cette droite sociale cette
droite Gauliste qui a une perspective
car là la perspective de Lauren voquier
c'est simplement d'être président de la
République on dirait c'est un peu le
François Baayou de des républicain
aujourd'hui qui veut simplement être
président l'affrontement qui vient c'est
Lauren voquier Édouard Philippe à droite
c'est ça ah bah je pense que pour
l'instant Édouard Philippe est en tout
cas en pôle position est loin devant
Laurent voquier il a beau avoir été le
premier ministre d'Emmanuel Macron
Édouard Philippe je pense que
aujourd'hui c'est celui qui est le mieux
positionné c'était vous pierre qui
disait pour pour rassembler macroniste
et et LR évidemment bien sûr ceux qui
sont derrière je pense au Xavier
Bertrand au David Lisnard ils sont là en
embuscade mais ils sont encore loin der
a du travail à faire Michel les
primaires vous en pensez quoi moi je
alors là vraiment si on veut s'ils
veulent continuer dans la décomposition
de la politique on fait pas mieux on
s'est aperçu quand même ce que ça a
donné les primaires je vois pas au bout
de combien de temps on comprendra que
les primaires c'est catastrophique bon
c'est catastrophique parce que les gens
ne se ne se raccommodent jamais on l'a
vu au Parti socialiste on l'a vu plus
récemment chez républicainson ça ça
marche jamais alors s'ils sont pas
capables de se mettre avant sur une une
personnalité et de l'imposer au français
avant de se déchirer dans les caméras de
télévision franchement ils sont pour
rien est-on en train d'assister à la
chute de la maison Mélenchon c'est un
autre thème cette semaine en tout cas
plusieurs enquêtes journalistiques
mettent en lumière Sophia Chikirou
député insoumise de Paris il s'agit
d'une très proche de l'ex-candidat à la
présidentielle il lui a notamment
reprocher un management brutal avec ses
équipes elle est aussi soupçonnée par la
justice d'avoir surfacturé certaines
prestations lors de la campagne de 2017
du côté de la France insoumise un mot
d'ordre circuler il y a rien à voir les
rémunérations de sopia chquiro elles
sont publiques elles sont publi donc
j'invite les journalistes qui font ce
travail à aller sur le site de la Haute
Autorité de la transparence et de la vie
publique j'ai bien compris avec beaucoup
de sexisme d'ailleurs qu'on essaie de
dénoncer comme on l'a fait à mathil
Panau comme on l'a fait à à Rachel keké
on essaie de de dénoncer des femmes qui
ont un caractère qui ont une influence
très importante dans la France à soumise
je trouvais ça assez au oui oui il y a
du sexisme Hélène il y a un malaise à la
France insoumise aujourd'hui bah
clairement il y a un malaise à la France
insoumise la personnalité de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon je pense qu'elle reste elle
restera au-dessus ça par contre la
maison Mélenchon elle est totalement
fragilisée et ce qui se passe avec
l'affaire Chikirou c'est la révélation
du système clanique qui se passe à la
France insoumise vous l'avez dit sopia
Chikirou c'est un management brutal des
dividendes qu'elle s'est versé elle-même
des soupçons descrquré aggravés des 11
collaborateurs en un an à l'Assemblée
nationale auprès d'elle et qui venait la
boule au ventre travaille avec elle et
pour
autant sopia chquirou extrêmement proche
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon je pense que comme
Adrien catnin elle sera totalement
réhabilitée dans le clan Mélenchon donc
ça va encore plus révéler le clivage qui
existe aujourd'hui au sein de la France
insoumise avec les bons soldats manuel
Bompard mathil Panou sopia Chikirou
entre autres et ceux qu'on appelle les
frondeurs de la France insoumise Alexis
Corbière madame garideau Daniel Simonet
Clémentine otin qui ont voulu un peu
plus de de démocratie au sein du parti
et qui vont s'appuyer sur ce genre
d'argument pour pour se faire on va
faire un duel les amis on va faire un
duel si vous voulez bien Sion à la chute
de la maison Jean-Luc Mélanchon une
question deux opinions très différentes
sur ce plateau deux invités qui ne sont
pas du tout d'accord d'un côté pierre de
l'autre notre ami Emmanuel vous allez
nous dire pourquoi selon vous pierre
vous avez 45 secondes vous savez comment
ça marche non on n'assiste pas à la
chute de la maison Mélenchon malgré
cette affaire Chikirou je ne crois pas
qu'on assiste à la mais la chute de la
maison Mélenchon parce que la maison
Mélenchon subit d'année en année un
certain nombre de de de de de
problématiques judiciaires notamment des
des événements judiciaire on a vu les
perquisitions ils s'en sont relevés on a
vu l'affaire catenins ils s'en sont
relevés je ne crois pas qu'on assiste à
cela parce que justement ils font la
démonstration qu'ils ont un mode de un
mode de fonctionnement très clanique où
ils se protègent les uns des autres y
compris dans les mauvais moments et dans
les mauvais moments qui passent pas et
qui passe pas du tout dans l'opinion
publique non plus parce que laffaire
quin ça laisse des traces à l'extérieur
ah il y a il y a un chrono donc je ne
pense pas que la chute soit imminente en
revanche évidemment ça va reposer des
questions et légitimes d'ailleurs de
démocratie interne de questions de de
fonctionnement de ce que la France
insoumise a envie de faire sur sur le
plan politique et que en cela oui sans
doute ça va ça va les murs vont trembler
mais la maison n'est pas est loin d'être
écroulé la maison brûle Emmanuel oui je
pense que la maison brûle parce que là
on on on touche à une personnalité qui
est la plus proche de de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon c'est entre guillemets l'ange
noire de Mélenchon et et Mélenchon est
en train de montrer au monde avec cette
affaire Chikirou qu'il qu'il est dans la
vie l'inverse de ce qu'il défend dans la
politique et ça ça peut pas ça peut plus
marcher aujourd'hui j'ajoute aussi que
sopia Chikirou au-delà de de tout ce
qu'on lui reproche c'est quelqu'un qui
est qui est capable d'être juge et parti
c'est-à-dire que là il y a un conflit
d'intérêt monstrueux et si la justice va
jusqu'au bout et qu'elle tombe je pense
que les langues qui n'osent pas se
délier aujourd'hui vont se délier vont
demander des comptes parce que dans le
groupe pour parler poliment excusez-moi
de la trivialité mais ils ont qu'une
envie c'est de se la faire tellement
qu'elle répile vous n'êtes pas
raisonnable Michel vous voulez bien nous
trancher ce ce débat qui vous a
convaincu entre Pierre et Emmanuel euh
moi je pense que la maison Mélenchon est
très euh va être en tout cas très remué
dans les dans les mois qui viennent
alors euh je pense que pour deux raisons
hein toute la raison je suis entièrement
d'accord avec euh votre analyse mais
deuxièmement il y a il me semble dans la
stratégie de mitteran une volonté de
détruire les autres c'està-dire détruire
d'abord enfin oui comparaison n'est pas
raison alors d'abord de détruire euh
fort qui est détruit tout seul ensuite
de détruire Eric Rousell qui
effectivement prend une à une certaine
élégance et une certain un certain
charisme dans la gauche donc il détruit
tout le monde en se disant j'en
profiterai à la fin et ça moi je trouve
que c'est toujours une stratégie
difficile parce qu'on finit par se
détruire d'abord pierre cette affaire
révèle quelque chose c'est le symptôme
de quelque chose à la France insoumise
ben c'est le symptôme d'un
fonctionnement qui ne va pas enfin je
pense que là pour la peine alors certes
tout le monde a droit à la présomption
d'innocence mais il y a quelque chose
quand même d'extrêmement grave de ce qui
se joue et de ce qui a été mis à jour
dans cette affaire mais y compris par le
passé je cité l'affaire des
perquisitions euh l'affaire catnince et
aujourd'hui laaffire Chikirou quand
j'entends des députés de la France
insoumise n expliquer que de toute façon
quoi qu' fait aujourd'hui nos petits
camarades de la France insoumise on les
défendra jusqu'au bout non pardon il y a
un moment donné il faut se remettre en
question si la France insoumis aspire un
jour à gouverner il va falloir à un
moment donné qu'elle soit un peu à la
hauteur des enjeux et de ce qui se passe
et de ce qui se dit aussi dans la dans
la France chez les Français je veux dire
c'est inadmissible de voir que
aujourd'hui les députés défendent Sofia
Chikirou non on doit lui demander des
compes à sopia Chikirou et encore une
fois elle a le droit à la présomption
d'innocence donc que la justice passe et
puis qu'elle s'en explique après je
trouve toujours qu'il y a du deux poid
de mesure vous voyez il y a quand même
une forme d'acharnement assez fréquent
quand même du côté de la France
insoumise en ce moment je vous rappelle
qu'il y a quand même une petite affaire
d'un ministre garde des saau qui est mis
en examen qui va passer devant devant la
justice et donc ça tout personne ne
parle quelle transition pierre quelle
transition parce qu'on va on on va
l'entendre on va é on va écouter Éric
duup pométi qui justement réagissit
cette affaire
Chikirou j'ai vu que certains médias
annoncent
une tempête judiciaire à venir monsieur
moi je suis infiniment respectueux
de la présomption d'innocence et je veux
dire à ce stade que si la justice doit
travailler elle travaillera j'ajoute en
toute en toute indépendance mais je
pense que certains
éléphistes réfléchiront à la façon dont
en d'autres temps ils ont traité
certaines présomptions d'innocence c'est
du pain béni pour ceux qui n'aiment pas
qui n'apprécie pas la France insoumis
cette affaire bah non mais moi je trouve
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon et ça ça garde
rapproché sont en voie de marchéisation
alors pour les plus jeunes de nos
téléspectateurs George marché avait
conduit le Parti communiste à des à des
sommets électorau dans les années 80 18
20 % puis ensuite il est devenu une
telle caricature de lui-même que ils en
ont eu marre d'être représenté entre
guillemets par un clown et alors je suis
pas en train de dire que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon est un clown mais je trouve
que il devient une caricature de
lui-même son équipe rapprochée à vouloir
défendre l'indéfendable devient des
caricatures de ce qu'il de ce qu'il
défend et de ce qu'il reproche au reste
de au reste de la vie politique et et
c'est c'est en cela que que je dis oui
c'est du pain béni naturellement mais
c'est du pain béni qui est qui est quand
même très fortement alimenté par ceux
qui sont au cœur de
l'histoire ils sont en train de faire
tout ce qu'il faut pas faire ils ne
ratent pas une seule occasion de rater
une bonne occasion de se rattraper donc
ça va ça va ça va finir par les
poursuivre certaines langues sont se
délient progressivement à la FR soumise
on va voir euh ce ce tweet de Gérard
Miller cette semaine qui était
confondateur du média un média donc qui
était proche de la France insoumise à
l'époque il écrit la chose suivante en
parlant de sopia Chikirou elle n'est pas
le monstre terrifiant qu'on écrit ici ou
là elle ne mérite ni cet excès d'honneur
ni cette indignité mais sa violence
toutous asimute et sa funeste conviction
que la fin justifie les moyens sont des
symptômes de ce avec quoi la France
aoumise doit rompre pour être à la
hauteur de l'aventure mélanchonienne euh
on voit il y a très peu de gens qui
acceptent de parler actuellement la
France insoumise pourquoi HL parce que
c'est mais on en revient toujours au
système clanique si on lève la voix on
est évincé
des bah les frondeurs les hatins les
garideaux les Corbières ont été
quasiment évanés de tes les instances
dirigeantes alors que bon parpanau c'est
la méritocratie au sein du parti ils
élèvent pas la voix parce qu'ils ont
peur de de pas de pas mais c'est des
élus de la nation ce sont des élus de la
nation ils ont peur à ce point de d'un
chef éventuel de part expriment c'est
ceux c'est finalement aussi plus
facilement leurs alliés de la nu ceux
qui avaient un doute sur encore
l'existence de la nuupè je pense que là
on est quasiment sû qu'elle est morte et
enterrée la nuupes ça a commencé avec
Chikirou qui fait une comparaison entre
Rousell et et un collaborationniste et
et euh et et avec Dorio exactement et là
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui les allés de
la nuupes ne vont plus gêner pour pour
dénoncer les la façon dont la France en
soumis agit et et la nupessou la nup
j'ai l'impression qu'on l'annonce morte
toutes les semain personne pardonnez-moi
qui sprimé publiquement au sein de la
France insoumise c'est une élu qui avait
elle-même officiell s'est exprimé au
moment de l'affaire catenance c'est
Madame Pascal bord je crois je j'oublie
son nom mais mais ils sont très peu ils
veulent pas et d'ailleurs dans le
documentaire de complément d'enquête qui
a été diffusé cette semaine il y a des
offs qui ont été qui ont été diffusés et
mis à l'antenne et et et certains
disaient aux journaliste vous m'assurez
vraiment que que vous ne dites pas que
que je vous ai dit ça vous parlez de la
député à fille Pascal
Martin pas la nuupess toutes les
semaines elle mort un peu plus là c'est
on sen rapproche ou qu'est-ce qui se
passe mais si vous voulez qu'elle meure
la
nuupessee veut qu'elle meure cette
nupesse mais la gauche est condamnée à
s'entendre si elle veut gouverner demain
donc à un moment donné ça sera peut-être
pas la nup ça sera autre chose mais je
veux dire Fabien Roussel Jean-Luc
Mélenchon Olivier fort marine tondeler
sont condamnés à s'entendre s'ils
veulent gouverner ils s prennent mal par
ils s prennent très très mal mais on
pensait pas on pensait pas que d'abord
on pensait pas queanl mchon pourrait
toutes ces affaires faire près de 22 % à
l'élection présidentielle on ne pensait
pas jusqu'à la veille des élections
législatives que la gauche pourrait se
réunir pour pouvoir porter des
candidatures communes aux élections
législatives on pensait pas qu'elle
ferait ce score on pensait pas
aujourd'hui comptenu de de l'état de
faite de la gauche dispersée en conflit
permanent que dans les sondages quand
elle est rassemblé elle est devant le
Front national pour l'élection
européennees ce que je veux dire c'est
que voilà il existe quand même cette
gauche dans le peuple qui a envie de la
voir rassembler donc je dire les
invectives aujourd'hui les aventures
personnelles que ce soit cell de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ou cell de Fabien
Rousel elles seront à un moment donné
contesté par la base elles seront
contesté par un certain nombre d'acteurs
politiques intellectuels et cetera donc
aujourd'hui bon chacun va de son de son
de sa stratégie je pense que demain tout
ça a vocation à se rassembler donc oui
elle va pas très bien la nupè
aujourd'hui demain elle se repensera
elle se renouvera nécessairement un
éternel optimiste oui il faut Michel
mais non il il y a un personnage
Mélenchon donc c'est vrai qu'il échappe
un peu qui peut échapper à nos analyses
parce que mais quand même moi je trouve
que il est cel leer finalement des deux
combats qui représentent quand même la
gauche c'estàd un combat sur les femmes
Adrien
cantenis embêtant hein et et et le
combat sur l'argent et sur la
prévarication c'est sopia chikou en
étant solidaire de ces deux là il
devient quand même un leader classique
si je veux dire
éclanique qui ne voit pas à quel point
même ses colèes peuvent dissiper
les les troubles de ces deuxlà alors en
plus quand on parle de de de clown moi
je je pe pas parler cl ENF son son
attitude maintenant qui est quand même
exaspérée donc
exaspérante est à mon avis joue à mon
avis contre lui même si par certains
côtés en effet il est assez unique dans
son genre a tiré tous les enseignements
des émeutes de l'été dernier au mois de
juillet la France a les plus graves
émeutes urbaines de son histoire
contemporaine l'érruption de violence
qui a suivi la mort de naë abattu à bout
portant par un policier avait provoqué
la stupéfaction de la classe politique
cette semaine le gouvernement a réuni un
CNR un conseil national de la
refondation pour établir un diagnostic
de la situation quelques jours plus tôt
Emmanuel Macron a annoncé le déploiement
de 238 nouvelles brigades de gendarmerie
sur tout le territoire c'est le début du
commencement de la réponse de l'exécutif
en la matière écoutez Emmanuel Macron
leses émeutes sont intervenus je dirais
que la première réponse elle a été
donnée clair et fort par nos forces de
sécurité notre justice ça s'est stoppé
en quelques jours parce que vous avez eu
45000 forces de sécurité intérieure qui
étaient inédit sur le terrain vous avez
eu des milliers d'interpellations 4000
et que vous avez eu plus de 1000
comparitions immédiates il faut en effet
consolider la réponse régalienne dans la
durée mais c'est derrière un problème
qui est beaucoup plus compliqué bon les
émeutes ont lieu cet été pourquoi les
réponses tardent autant à venir hen
alors je pense que ils ont fait le
constat le gouvernement on peut quand
même leur donner ce gagelà le profil
très jeune des émetiers la difficulté de
certaines familles notamment
monoparental à exercé à exercé leur leur
leur autorité la question des réseaux
sociaux ça le constat il a été fait
l'urgence a été gérée déploiement des
forces de l'ordre euh 4000
interpellations pendant les émeutes euh
et et et euh Gérald armanin et éc du
pont morétien en première ligne l'ordre
républicain a été rétabli maintenant le
constat a été fait les réponses
n'arrivent pas et et et certains maères
qui étaient cette semaine au au CNR
émeut au Conseil national de la
refondation me disaient au téléphone
parce que je faisais un papier là-dessus
pour pour RMC me disait allez on va pas
tergiverser
50 ans on a le profil on on on il y a
des sociologues qui travaillent dessus
maintenant on attend des réponses
certains mères disent on a des
problématiques de logement on a des
problématiques en terme de relation
population police le diagnostic est fait
on a besoin de réponse et et pour
l'instant on nous dit dit que c'est fin
octobre que la première ministre va
donner des réponses concrètes à ce CNR
elles sont toujours extrêmement
attendues on voir le profil des
condamnés par la la justice suite à ses
émeutes vous en parliez Hélène les
condamnés type entre guillemets ce sont
des hommes 80 % des mises en cause 23
ans en moyenne 79 % d'entre eux sont de
nationalité française 38 % sont
titulaires d'un diplôme inférieur au
baccalauréat la motivation principale et
bien c'est l'opportunisme 41 % des cas
et seulement 8 % euh sont allés dans la
rue suite à l'émotion suscitée par la
mort de Naël c'est un rapport qui a été
publié fin août par l'administration
Emmanuel qu'est-ce que cela vous évoque
est-ce que voilà on a le profil des
condamnés line parlait d'un diagnostic
qui a été fait les réponses sont pas
aussi simple il y a pas de réponse
surtout qui sont données c'est surtout
ça effectivement Gérald Armana a donné
une réponse es qualité dans ses
fonctions de de de ministre de
l'Intérieur au moment des
émé silence oui mais depuis silence euh
le le la nouvelle le nouveau cap on
l'attend toujours le président de la
République a été extraordinairement
silencieux après après ses ses émeutes
la seule réponse qu'il a donné c'est à
Elisabeth Bourne succède ellisabeth
Bourne et puis alors maintenant on a le
le fameux Conseil national de la
refondation alors dans les années ces
deux dernières décennies quand on
voulait enterrer un sujet on faisait des
des États généraux puis ensuite un livre
blanc alors sous Emmanuel Macron on fait
un conseil national de la refondation le
dernier conseil de la National de la
Fondation a accouché de rien celui-là
accouchera de rien parce que de toute
façon ils ne savent pas comment le
prendre ils savent pas quelle réponse
donner et et le peu de répones qu'il
pourrait donner et qui sont de mon point
de vue fondamental pour pouvoir lutter
contre la montée des extrêmes des des
deux côtés de l' qui est politique il il
n'est pas prêt à les donner le président
de la République l'enjeu de ces émeutes
pierre c'était l'enjeu des quartiers
difficiles on parle beaucoup de de ces
quartiers des quartiers populaires oui
je pense que ce qui s'exprime à travers
les différentes révoltes que
que ça que ça démarre sur un sur un sur
un sujet de violence policière qui
abouti comme la mort dramatique du jeune
naë derrière tout ça il y a la question
de des inégalités territoriales et du
traitement différencié notamment de nos
institutions sur des publics différents
je
m'explique la question des contrôles off
faciè par exemple qui est posée par un
certain nombre d'acteurs associatifs est
une question qui devrait être
fondamental dans le dans le dans dans la
manière d'appréhender ce qu' s'est passé
il y a 3 mois avec les Ré volte dans les
quartiers populaires et pas que les
quartiers populaires c'est parce que
vous faisiez le le le le profil type des
des personnes qui ont été condamnées il
a il y a quelque chose de notable dans
ce qui s'est passé il y a 3 mois c'est
que des petites villes de province y
compris d'ailleurs des moyennes villes
he limoge montargie voilà il y a a des
villes quand même qui se sont réveiller
et révél aussi donc ce qui s'est exprimé
à ce moment-là c'était aussi un
sentiment d'abandon et je pense que
c'est ça qui est problématique on a nous
la semaine dernière on a fait un un
dossier spécial sur les euh de familles
et de victimes de violence policière qui
a interpellé le président de la
République sur à peu près tris points il
y a la question des contrôles faè
c'estàdire que c'est pas possible que
nous dans la rue on se fait pas
interpeller on n don pas no papiers
d'identité alors en revanche si vous
avez le teint un peu coloré on va venir
vojeu principal c'est le rapport avec la
police je pense qu'il y a un problème
avec le rapport de la police il y a ça
il y a quand même la question de
l'indépendance judiciair quand les
policiers
sont pris la main dans le sac et que
donc ils doivent passer il y a pas il y
a pas de condamnation systématique de
des policiers et puis oui je pense qu'il
y a plus généralement un rapport de la
police et une dernière chose parce que
je trouve que cette phrase est
formidable on a interrogé le sociologue
Laur Bonelli qui dit on s'aperçoit que
depuis une quarantaine d'années les
forces de l'ordre apparaissent pour
nombre de gouvernants comme une solution
miracle pour répondre au creusement des
inégalités c'est ça le problème c'est
que la seule réponse aujourd'hui c'est
plus de bleu dans les rues non ce que
dit votre voisin c'est que le l'enjeu
principal c'est le rapport avec la
police moi d'abord je pense que c'est un
enjeu mais il y a quand même un énorme
paradoxe d'abord il y a quand même 0 ou
75 % des Français euh qui trouve que la
police fait son boulot quand même c'est
important euh plus de 2/ers euh de ement
il y a un paradoxe qui est plus on
déclenche des mutes et par prétexte on
est d'accord on voit pas exactement
quand commence pour ça que c'est
tellement difficile à à à déceler c'est
que on ne voit pas quand et ce qui
déclenche une émeute de ce genre mais il
est évident que à ce moment-là les
français demandent plus de sécurité donc
tout ce qui est
insécurité manifeste favorise
effectivement un pouvoir autoritaire est
plutôt à droite donc le il me semble que
le grand le grand anger il est là
c'est-à-dire à aboutir à autre chose que
ce qu'on voulait mais qui ne à mon avis
renforcera plutôt le pouvoir de la
police Emmanuel sur la
police moi j'ai j'ai j'ai du mal je vais
peut-être pas être très populaire en
disant ça mais j'ai du mal à à à
accepter l'idée qu'on parle de qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont voulu dire ils n'ont rien
voulu dire du tout euh je veux dire au
bout de 48 he on était plus dans Naël on
était dans du vandalisme pour faire du
shopping sur les Champs-Élysées faut
regarder les choses comme comme elles
sont donc là je suis désolé le le le
l'inégalité territoriale c'est de la
poudre aux yeux la question là c'est pas
la police la question c'est qu'il y a
des gens qui se comportent comme des
voyou qui font du du du vandalisme
touristique et et et chopinien et et et
et la réponse elle doit être à la
hauteur on dans un état de droit on ne
s'exprime pas comme ça c'est pas une
expression voilà et je pense que à à
laisser l'idée que on a le droit de se
comporter comme ça et qu'ensuite il faut
ouvrir un débat sur la l'attitude de la
police on est mais mais pardon mais
complètement à côté de la plaque c'est
ma c'est ma c'est ma ma conviction
profonde pierre vous répond mais oui
parce que bon je je comprends je
comprends votre analyse je c'est pas
juste analyse jusqu on a on a montré les
chiffres avec voilà le
l'opportunismeopportunismeich parz de pr
je je crois pas quand on vit la
situation de d'un certain nombre
d'habitants des quartiers populaires ou
y compris d'ailleurs en milieu rural je
crois pas que quand on vit cette
situation où on est discriminé à
l'embauche on est contrôlé par la police
on subit des violences policières qui
aboutissent parfois à des décès
dramatiques on a une égypenne qui
contrôle la police et qui est pas
franchement indépendante ce que je veux
dire le sentiment d'injustice il est
permanent je je je je le dis souvent
peut-être trop mais je trouve que il y a
aussi un climat politique qui conduit à
C à ces violences je dis pas que je la
légitime mais vous voyez Emmanuel Macron
il a renoncé à deux par deux reprises à
des projets qui était des projets
auquels il tenaent c'était Notre-Dame
des Land et la taxe carbone à quel
moment il décide de renoncer à ses
projets il renonce à ses projet parce
qu'il y a des violences qui émanent de
de de de la Zade pour l'aéroport not
d'And et puis les violences qu'on a vu
qui ont fait le tour de du monde autour
de des champélysé bon bah ça ça
participe pas d'un climat où il y a une
volonté de discussion avec les
représentants associatifs au niveau
local qui demandent pas grand-chose
encore une fois les familles de victimes
qui sont exprimé dans quelqu semaines
dernière elles demandent des choses très
concrètes les associations ont rencontré
Elisabeth borne et visiblement elles
sont plus ou moins elles sont déçu de
voilà de de ce qui a de ce qui s'est
raconté à matigon clairement le cnrme a
été vécu comme une forme de thérapie
collective éem thérapie collective alors
il y avait pourtant c'était assez
ambitieux on avait se ou h ministres on
avait une dizaine de maires touché
particulièrement par les violences
urbaines il y avait des représentants
d'élus locaux il y avait des
sociologues voilà il y avait également
des représentants syndicaux des
représentants syndicaux ce qui en
ressort c'est le constat est fait on a
compris le message on attend des
réponses concrètes et maintenant l'état
donne rendez-vous fin octobre pour
annoncer des mesures ce sera face aux
quelques 200 300 mères qui avaient été
déjà reçu à l'Élysée c'est en juillet
dernier par Emmanuel Macron façon de
boucler la boucle on nous dit he c'est
ce qu'on nous dit en off à Matignon et
ben ils attendent plus que ça maintenant
direction les États-Unis à présent où on
a vécu une semaine tout simplement
historique pour la première fois le chef
de la Chambre des Représentants le
speaker a été destitué tenez-vous bien
s'il a été invité à aller voir ailleurs
c'est à l'initiative de son propre camp
le camp républicain où une minorité pro
Donald Trump considère qu'il est trop
mou pas assez radical face notamment aux
démocrates on va écouter la réaction de
Kevin
McCarty je crains que l'institution ne
se soit effondrée aujourd'hui parce
qu'il est impossible de faire le travail
si h personnes qui représentent 94 ou 96
% de l'ensemble de la conférence peuvent
s'associer avec l'ensemble de l'autre
comment
gouverner Emmanuel c'est un chaos
politique inédit auquel on assiste oui
c'est c'est c'est assez compliqué parce
qu'en fait il faut distinguer plusieurs
groupes il faut distinguer les militants
des républicains des adhérents des
républicains des élus et du corps
électoral les militants des républicains
c'est-à-dire la la partie la plus
minoritaire mais la plus active et ce
sont des des des trumpophiles jusqu'à la
mort euh le reste et fondamentalement
opposé au président à l'ancien président
Trump j'en veux pour preuve et et les
élus ont envie aussi de garder leur
poste c'estàdire que derrière l'élection
présidentielle ce ce profile aussi des
élections à la chambre des représentants
et au Congrès dans les dans dans les
états or Donald Trump leur a
donné la preuve par le vote au moment
des midterm qu'il est l'assurance tour
risque des démocrates partout
partout c'est comme ça que Biden a sauvé
son a sauvé son mandat partout où Donald
Trump a imposé ses propres candidats au
midterm ils ont été battus donc il y a
ils ont changé les règles c'est la
raison c'est la raison de ce chaos c'est
que normalement il faut une majorité au
sein du parti républicain pour pouvoir
destituer le speaker pour faire plaisir
aux amis de Donald Trump le speaker qui
vient d'être destitué a accepté que un
seul élu puisse provoquer un référendum
et et et donc tout vient tout vient de
là donc et et et moi ce que je crains
pour les républicains c'est que il va
finir par gagner les primaires parce que
Ron Detis Donald Trump ouais alors
justement on va écouter Donald Trump
parce que cette semaine c'est'est ouvert
un procès au civil contre lui on lui
reproche d'avoir fait de fausses
déclarations pour gonfler son patrimoine
afin d'obtenir des prêts favorables peu
importe les affaires peu importe ce
qu'il passe ce qui se passe au concret
Trump dit être focus sur toute autre
chose écoutez-le
beaucoup de gens m'ont appelé au sujet
de la position de speaker tout ce que je
peux dire c'est que nous ferons ce qui
est le mieux pour le pays et pour le
parti républicain il y a des gens
formidables accepteriez-vous le poste
beaucoup de gens m'ont posé la question
je suis concentré nous sommes en tête je
ne sais pas si vous lisez trop les
journaux mais nous avons une avance
d'environ 50 points dans la course
présidentielle je entièrement làdessus
si je peux les aider au cours du
processus je le ferai mais nous avons
des gens formidables du parti
républicain qui pourrait faire un
excellent travail en tant que président
de la Chambre des
représentantsichel Donald Trump il est
en train de tuer les républicains
historiques comme on les a on les a
connu par le passé moi je trouve surtout
qu'il est en train de de créer une
Amérique
ingouvernable je trouve effectivement
qu'il fait la distension dans dans dans
son camp mais
que je veux pas dire la la guerre civile
mais tel qu'on voit les choses
apparaître il quand même il on voit
qu'on entraîne à l'opposition mais alors
frontale des deux camps à à personnes
près qui étaient déjà pour l'opposition
frontale moi je trouve ça très dangereux
je trouve sa position très dangereuse et
elle est en plus affaiblie elle est en
plus confortée par
l'affaiblissement du président de la
République actuelle sur lequel quand
même on a des
interrogations moi je crains vra que ces
élections futur entraînent une rép
partition de l'Amérique pierre là-dessus
fake je crois que ce qui divise les
républicains c'est cette espèce de mythe
d'un État centralisé et je pense qu'il y
a aussi une part de d'autodestruction de
ce que peut-être la vision d'un État
américain et je pense que c'est aussi ça
qui se joue moi j'ai pas bien compris
donc j'ai cherché à comprendre ce qu'il
se jouait en ce moment aux États-Unis
parce que je ne suis pas un expert et
j'ai lu ce Libé des historiens hier dans
Libération et hier a cet historien qui
explique effectivement ce qui s'est joué
aussi là c'est la destruction de l'État
et la volonté des républicains les plus
radicaux c'est de montrer que les
institutions nuisent aux libertés il
après et d'ailleurs dans la dans le
mandat de qui a été celui de Trump
lui-même a nommé des postes de ministres
je pense au ministre de la de de
l'éducation par exemple qui était
totalement hostile à l'éducation
publique et il a nommé quand même
quelqu'un qui était qui avait vocation à
détruire donc ce que je veux dire c'est
que il y a là chez cette partie làà des
républicains cette volonté de nuire à
l'état de ce qui'est la fonction même de
l'État donc il y a la volonté la
stratégie du Chao qui a quand même été
beaucoup celle de de de Donal Donald
Trump je sais pas comment tout ça va
aboutir j'ai j'ai bien peur que ça ça
peut profiter à Donald Trump et là et à
chaque procès à chaque procès donc un
procès s ouvert cette semaine chaque
procès on a l'impression qu'il augmente
sa popularité oui alors ce qui est assez
intéressant sur ce sujet là il a été
interrogé sur le speaker lui qui est
quand même qui presque diligente he qui
est le diligant de ce groupe de H
frondeurs au sein de la Chambre des
Représentants il s'est exprimé en disant
euh au lieu d'avoir ses guerres
intestines il vaut mieux combattre la
gauche radicale bon il fait euh so il
prend soi-disant un peu de hauteur en
réalité effectivement je pense que ce ce
chaos le SERT il est même question que
peut-être il pourrait prendre la place
de Kevin mcarti euh à laadant à la
Chambre des Représentants bon ça ça
interroge ce qui est aussi important à
souligner je pense que c'est euh cette
crise des républicains donc qui est
national aux États-Unis la même un
impact international parce que on a même
l'Ukraine qui SM quête de pas avoir une
aide supplémentaire parce qu'elle est
conditionnée par ce budget qui est
encore en cours de discussion avec cette
crise je pense que le retentissement est
assez important d'habitude les amis vous
le savez on termine l'émission par un
top flop mais c'est une semaine un peu
particulière à public Scéna on a appris
la disparition de Jean-Pierre alcabach à
l'âge de 86 ans il était le fondateur de
votre chaîne préférée il en a été le
président entre 2000 et 2009 petit clin
d'œil petit hommage à celui qui avait un
style une façon inimitable de cuisiner
les politiques regardez soyez pas
désobligeants monsieur c'est tout à fait
inu arrivez pas vous mettre dans votre
petite tête que moi aussi j'ai un
cerveau et un cerveau qui est capable de
raisonner de réfléchir et de formuler
des propositions et des appréciations
quelle couleur vous préférez pour le
mur le mur quel mur comment quel mur le
mur sur lequel votre réform to il va se
fracasser bonjour Marine Le Pen bonjour
vous n'avez pas honte pardon vous n'avez
pas honte honte de quoi vous n'avez pas
de regret non mais vous de de qu
parlez-vous monsieur le Cabache vous
n'étiez pas je vous reconnais bien je
vous reconnais bien là dans la
provocation je reconnaissez bien là dans
la provocation Michel vous l'avez bien
connu hein je l'ai bien connu avec des
hauts et des bas hein comme tous ceux
qui ont connu lkabach et puis finalement
plutôt les haut parce que c'était
quelqu'un qui avait un une noble
conception de notre métier finalement
qui voulait être le premier et au fond
euh B on comprend qu'il va être le
premier à donner un scoop le premier à
voir l'homme politique le plus euh euh
le plus important du moment et moi ce
que je retient plus que les les
émissions comme carte sur table qui ont
joué un rôle formidable hein mais on on
voit comment elles sont conçues comment
elles été justement appuyé sur du
Amel Hel cabage moi ce que je retiens
quand même c'est la la virtuosité de
l'interview en 12
minutes garan moi je vous garanti que je
l'ai fait aussi pour RTL ben j'étais
beaucoup moins bonne que lui alors je
reconnais c'est en 12 minutes faire dire
à quelqu'un en l'écoutant bien tout en
ayant dans l'autre oreille ce qu'on veut
lui faire
dire là-dessus il était un des maîtres
voilà Emmanuel qu'est-ce que vous
retenez vous de de Jean-Pierre alcabache
il a fait basculer un monde
je trouve avant
lui dans l'interview la personnalité
était la vedette après lui dans
l'interview c'est elabage qui est la
vedette euh la meilleure preuve en est
c'est que on disait pas je vais sur
Europe 1 être interviewé on disait je
vais chez Elkabach et et alors ça ça
présente aussi évidemment des des des
des des problèmes mais mais voilà je
pense que il a eu au moins cela
c'est-à-dire cette capacité à
éditorialiser tellement son interview
qu'il prenait le pas sur la personne qui
l' interviewit pierre il vous a inspiré
bah on rêve tous en tant que journaliste
d'avoir une carrière d'interviewur comme
Elkabach je j'espère que je je
terminerai pas ma carrière politique
médiatique pardon journalistique
politique c'est un oui c'est je vous
assure que non
journalistique comme comme il l'a fait
non s'il vous plaît
mais mais je je trouve qu'il y a quelque
chose de notable moi je ma génération
connaît le cabach par effectivement les
images que que vous red diffusez un
punchliner extraordinaire je je trouve
qu'il a bénéficié d'un moment que moi en
tant que journaliste je lui a envie
cette espèce de rareté de la parole
politique et je trouve que c'est ça c le
caractère aussi très solennel très
charismatique de ces de ces moments de
télévision où aujourd'hui la parole
politique elle est permanente tout le
temps on
des politiques surtout et n'importe quoi
tout le temps donc je trouve que voilà
c'est des moments comme ça que avec la
pression qui était aussi des moments
comme ceuxl il le dit je crois que c'est
sal qui l'exlique très bien non c'est
Alan diamel qui l'explique très bien que
tout le temps il l'appelit à 6h du matin
tu es sûr je pose cette question est-ce
que c'est la bonne machin et il a fait
mais émergé aussi une génération de de
journalistes donc je trouve que c'est
c'est aussi NOTAM peut-être je sais pas
alors moi moi le le regard que j'ai sur
jeanemp Cabal c'est moi jeune
journaliste arrivant à Europe 1 Laté
2016 parce que j a travaillé avant
d'être à RMC et c'était encore la grand
messe de Jean-Pierre l cabach et j'ai
exactement le sentiment dont vous parlez
ce sentiment de c'est l'interview
d'elkabach il a qui demain et on
imaginait entre nous presque quelle
quelle allait être sa première question
le vous n'avez pas honte le mur on
limitait entre nous et c'est c'est c'est
un mythe Jean-Pierre elcabach donc oui
forcément moi c'est un intervieweur
politique qui m'a qui qui m'a toujours
inspiré et puis et puis j'ai fait j'ai
appelé certaines personnalités
politiques suite à ODC de Jean-Pierre l
cabach pour pour RMC pour faire des
réactions et puis le truc qui revient
c'est bah en fait il nous faisait dire
ce qu'on avait pas envie de dire et
c'est ça le le talent d' grand
intervieur merci beaucoup président
l'Arch c'est la fin de cette émission
merci à tous les quat merci d'avoir
participé salut à vous derrière votre
écran me disant lauette que vous êtes de
plus en plus nombreux à nous suivre
merci à vous je vous rappelle que vous
pvez retrouver cette émission replay sur
notre plateforme publicsena.fr on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine même jour
même heure et même endroit bye
[Musique]
bye